nos dicen que un pastelito requiere 35
gramos de azúcar y 50 gramos de harina
vamos a resaltar estos datos un
pastelito requiere 35 gramos de azúcar y
50 gramos de harina mientras que un pan
que citó
requiere 30 gramos de azúcar y 65 gramos
de harina su zona necesita usar al menos
460 gramos de azúcar para hacer
pastelitos y panquecitos vamos a
resaltarlo susana necesita usar al menos
460 gramos de azúcar para hacer
pastelitos y panquecitos y no quiero
usar más de 970 gramos de harina usemos
otro color
no quiero usar más de 970 gramos de
harina
vamos a formar un sistema de
desigualdades que representan las
condiciones de susana se hace el número
de pastelitos que hace y el número de
panquecitos que hace escribe una
desigualdad que represente la condición
basada en el número de gramos de azúcar
la condición basada en el número de
gramos de azúcar es esta que resaltamos
en azul necesita usar al menos 460
gramos de azúcar para hacer pastelitos y
panquecitos veamos cómo podemos escribir
esto cuánta azúcar va a usar ella para
los pastelitos bueno nos dicen que ella
requiere 35 gramos de azúcar por
pastelito por lo que la cantidad total
de azúcar que va a usar por pastelito
van a ser los 35 gramos por la cantidad
de pastelitos que va a hacer
ese es el número de pastelitos 35 por c
ese es el total de azúcar que va a
ocupar ella por cada pastelito 35 gramos
por pastelito multiplicada por el número
de pastelitos que va a ser y cuántos
gramos de azúcar va a usar para los
panquecitos
bueno aquí nos dicen que un parquecito
uno solo requiere 30 gramos de azúcar
así que vamos a esto sumarle los 30
gramos de azúcar del pan que citó
multiplicado por el número de
panquecitos que va a hacer que es m 30
por m
este es el azúcar total de los
pastelitos y este el azúcar total de los
panquecitos si sumamos ambos vamos a
tener el total de azúcar que ella está
usando y nos dicen que ella necesita
usar al menos 460 gramos de azúcar todo
esto está en gramos así que vamos a
escribirlo directamente todo esto tiene
que ser mayor o igual ya que es al menos
460 gramos de azúcar para hacer a ambos
pastelitos y panquecitos y así
escribimos la desigualdad que representa
la condición basada en el número de
gramos de azúcar que es esta condición
de acá la siguiente pregunta es escribe
una desigualdad que represente la
condición basada en el número de gramos
de harina y esta condición la tenemos
aquí en naranja ella quiere usar no más
de 970 gramos de harina
así que es no más de 970 gramos como
expresamos esto como una desigualdad
bueno pues cuánta harina vamos a
necesitar para los pastelitos nos dicen
50 gramos de harina para los pastelitos
entonces cada pastelito necesita 50
gramos de harina
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por el
número de pastelitos que va a hacer que
lo denotamos con c 50 por c esto es toda
la harina que va a necesitar solamente
para los pastelitos y para los
panquecitos ella usa 65 gramos de harina
por cada pan que citó se usan 65 gramos
de harina que vamos a multiplicar por el
número total de panquecitos que va a
hacer que es m 65 por m
y todo esto debe ser menor o igual a
nuestra restricción que es no más de 970
gramos de harina así que esto debe ser
menor o igual a 970 gramos y con esto
terminamos de hecho ustedes pueden usar
esto para calcular qué pares de heces y
m se cumplen con ambas desigualdades y
así encontrar la combinación de
pastelitos y panquecitos que ella puede
hacer que satisfagan estas condiciones